comic book heroes and action films we
kind of assume
they appeal to kind of nerdy boys
essentially yeah
and you kind of forget there are lots of
nerdy women out there
who like these films yeah yeah
everyone's got their inner nerd
yeah well you are a proper nerd aren't
you uh i mean when it comes to harry
potter i'm a massive
massive nerd well we know that because
you posted this picture is this your
12th
or you're about 12 or 13 here this is
margot robbie look how uncool
do you know what's particularly pathetic
about this picture a couple things
really
um number one i'll let you point them
out
number one it's my birthday that's how i
chose to spend my birthday
oh yay what was in the cup
uh number two i'm drinking tea uh number
three
i'm wearing glasses even though i don't
need glasses i lied to the optometrist
because i wanted to have glasses like
that
now daniel i think you were where are
you at harry potter fan and i love harry
potter i just to get round to reading
the last one
okay so i just i was
are you kidding me so you've read one to
six and you haven't read the seven
yeah i don't know are you actually
kidding
couldn't bear for twins i'm like not
going to be able to sleep tonight
worrying about you life is a game you
mean so
i just like you it's just you keep it on
the edge i mean this is insane to me
do you know another fun fact my husband
is your thing this is
fascinating i can go on about this
forever i'm
so sorry i brought this up i have no one
else to blame
oh no margo tell us i'll stop hijacking
the show after this
because i'm not here to publicize harry
potter
um my husband is in the harry potter
movies
i know i was like had you told me sooner
we would have been married very quickly
but he was
um an extra he was like when he was a
little kid he's like one of the
slaughtering
extras you know when draco like pushes
some kids out of the way to
to see buckbeak in the third book yeah
he pushes my husband out of the way i
know
cause john i know you certainly were a
big fan of pizza was it
is it called zepe zepe zeppie's zeppe's
please keep me alive man
yeah i mean real for real it kept me
alive because what you were working in a
bar
i was i was doing any job i could to
make any money i could and i was
bouncing at a bar next door
uh this is a strip of stores on a beach
in southern california
and i was trying to just get by because
the cost of living out there is
atrocious and the place next door was a
deep dish pizza place called zeppies
and they ran a promotion if you could
eat a 12-slice deep-dish pizza in one
city
you get it free and you get a coupon for
another pizza
after week i put them sons of
out of business
they stopped the promotion halfway
through the week and literally
closed down shortly there
yeah for about a week and a half i was
the zeppy's pizza eating champion thank
you
[Applause]
yeah my next match is december 26th
madison square garden
oh my god wow yeah for the holidays i'm
gonna see bumble bee like 200 times just
like everybody here
yeah and then right after that i'm i'm
going to wwe
wow but i've seen you do a thing and i
like you're on a suit but can you do it
the the deadlift thing
[Applause]
wow
thank you thank you i'm an elderly
gentleman
and a good sport and a very good sport
but let me tell you something december
26th of the master square garden won't
be so
[Applause]
[Music]
so there is a big grudge match at the
end and it's phenomenal the boxing at
the end
and there's incredible shots where for
both of you i don't know
how is there a way to do them you know
when you you've been punched and you
come around
and it's like looks like your face is
hanging off yeah yeah yeah
is there a technique to that there's two
ways to do it one is to get punched
and that works well
it really is true we did the slow motion
it's not worth it
and then there's one where bob clips me
and you you
put whatever you want in your mouth like
a little blood whatever and
you cough at the same time you're being
hit like ah
and that creates the effect without it
looking like
because people try to spit so you can
hit
no it doesn't work so you cough it out
you cough it out you literally go
and it creates this because what we did
was discuss
this mural of pain well we got the the
software
and put it in that camera there nice
yeah so it's like a high speed
so that you can slow it down i i'm just
talking words are coming out of my mouth
apparently it can do this thing so if we
demonstrate if you
i'm not going to ask you to hit me but
if you could pretend to hit me
right yeah yeah yeah really pretend
everything's on the pete yeah okay and
that was the last show in the graveyard
we dedicated a big black box around the
whole show
so if you can demonstrate so and i think
oh you have a glove
sorry excuse my is that the right one uh
yeah yeah yeah
okay okay
but you are pretending it's like being
home again
yeah you look way too happy
you look delighted
i really liked your movie i can't tell
you how much best film i've ever seen
you're all invited i'll buy you all
tickets
okay so if well stand up yeah okay and
so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put a little water in my mouth
so i cough the water yes okay now i'm
going to come across
this way boom
[Music]
it'll come to like your ear but then you
just turn
and it looks like i nailed you ready
ready on three one two
three
okay now let's do it okay
okay now now we get to watch that
back uh and this is i i guess this is
what they do in the movie
so here it is
[Music]
that's great
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely
you're like a photographer behind me
am i still going yeah god
that's important i've got a face like a
windsock
it was i uh uh i won an oscar for
directing a short film i didn't know you
could win oscars for short films but
there you are that happened
very exciting went to hollywood
marvelous wonderful uh and i sold a
script
uh to a company called uh miramax who
were very famous
and they let me uh i i came back home to
britain and i worked on the script and
they were paying me and it was lovely i
mean i bought up i bought my house and
all that stuff
uh and we did it over the fullness of
that and they said okay we're gonna
we're gonna make this movie
so i uh they booked me on a flight to
new york and i was going to fly over
and start uh discussions about it i got
on the flight
got to the hotel uh a big dream car
outside got into the car
uh and the driver was a lovely guy i
called me he's called ralph
and he said to me what are you what are
you doing here and i said well i'm just
going down to begin work of my movie
we're going to start talking about
casting probably
and pre-production he said great and he
said i have to take you down to the
office
i said yeah and he said they'd have to
wait for you
and i said no so you probably don't have
to wait because we're probably going to
go for a meal and have some champagne
and stuff he said no i've been told to
wait
all right okay so uh but i still think
i'm a big shop by this time so i gave
him a big tip
i said you have that ralph thanks very
much you can wait if you like but we're
going to be a while
probably and i go into the offices uh
and and meet the guy who's in charge bob
who basically says we ain't going to do
this
it's over and that was it that was we
weren't going to do anything else
we weren't going to talk about
production we weren't going to uh
talk about other projects it was just
over there was the door
but your driver's waiting
and i got into the car and i was i was
sort of in shock
i didn't know what to what to do it was
my whole i had no money
i spent all my money i had no career as
an actor because that was over because i
decided to be a director and i was
laughing
i said it's over ralph was saying what's
happened to you i said
he was i was going to make a movie and i
know i'm not going to make a movie
and i'm going no i've got no money i've
got no career i've got nothing
and we got out of the car and he gave me
my tip back
and actually interesting we've got a
picture of you here you are yes
in the white house i met the man oh look
that was great
sharing laughs do you remember what you
were laughing about yeah no exactly what
was it about david cameron
to me
[Laughter]
no one is talking to him
president obama at the time was telling
me that i was his second favorite
character in the wire
oh yeah omar number one yeah omar was
his favorite so i laughed out loud as
you can see
like come on man
oh it's funny about why that is because
i love the hyena i love that hyena
and i again it was one of those crazy
ideas that the writer christina and i
hadn't
you know early development because in
the comic books
turns out it's really expensive so i had
to make one um
maybe if we had another one it will be
the second hyena but uh yeah
it wasn't until we were in
pre-production that everyone was like
huh how do we shoot
with a hyena because they're actually
very dangerous animals um it turns out
and there's one hyena in california just
one somewhere
i show this hyena who's appeared in a
few things apparently
um so we all went out there to to go
visit this hyena
and um realize that it would be
impossible to shoot with him they're
like well
and and the whole reason he's in a
bathtub in this scene is because he
likes to sit in a bathtub like when we
went to go meet him he
sat in his bathtub and we're like i love
this that he just you know um whatever
so we put that in the movie but
uh yeah they were like well anything he
touches is his
and um you can't take it back and i was
like oh well on a film set but we're
gonna need like the couch back for
example and
the set back and like my arm if you've
got you know
so we quickly realized that wasn't going
to be possible and we didn't want to do
you know
a guy in a green suit covered in dots
because that was going to be weird and
um
so we found a happy medium we had a
really really big dog
and then they cgi'd his fur and you know
body to look
like a hater that was a dog so that was
a big dog yeah so when you're eating
that thing is there a dog
yeah the big dog and me doing lady and
the oh
yeah so cute i could sort of tell it was
a real talk i could tell i could tell
daniel's not impressed no i am not doing
that
i have a pitbull at home though so i was
like i have a few dogs i love dogs i
know
when did you do the dj and chris was
that was that before stand up
i gave before i was a stand-up i did i
mean i was you know i'm from new york
and that's what we did back then and we
were disciples of grand master flash and
theodore and all these guys we'd go and
watch djs
and all my friends got together and we
pooled our money and we got dj equipment
and we played block parties and stuff
and
guys would rap before there were rap
records because it sounds so cool
it sounds so cool and then someone
showed us a picture of you djing
you look like a ball boy at wimbledon
it doesn't suggest cool you're a great
looking kid
oh man look at that now dj
dries i just did your sailboat now just
yeah oh never dj drifters it was dj
he's a real dj yes yes yeah yeah but i
just dressed the sound you know
i do dress for like when i'm when i'm
spitting bars you know rapping and that
but you know
idris alba mainly okay
now you were were you you were a gary
jemzy is this right
well i mean you know everyone was a
garage mc at one point everyone was like
cheating about it
you know i loved a bit of that
kate what was your dj name um winsley
baby
knickers i definitely was not
sadly i i've never had a dj name and
i've never heard you dj i'd love to he's
really good i would love it
thank you chris yeah thanks that's you
have to invite me now no i will
i don't know why i'd be surprised
because you're margot robbie living in
london so of course you did
but you did mix in some highfalutin
circles
yes oh yes this picture i don't know
where this picture came from oh okay
well
that's obviously you is that is that
sienna miller
yeah i think so and that's a princess is
it a beatrice one or a eugenie one
i can't tell by the picture everyone
kind of looks weird you're picking
everyone better than i can
uh i think it's one of them and then i
said
tell us who this is you know i know
but delicious it's prince harry i don't
normally go to a party where these kind
of
people are there that was a one-off
that doesn't normally happen my my
friends aren't royals
but anyway uh there of course is carol
vino you know is a good friend of mine
yeah and you were a suicide squad
together yeah yeah
she's she's awesome you know in uh the
suicide squad
you tattooed your cast members is this
right
yes because you're you're kind of you're
trained
so these are the tattoos you do yeah we
call them tomojis
okay and did you do them all the cast no
weirdly enough no one else wanted them
um
so just the two of us got the toe emojis
but everyone else got squad written on
them and
other people just would come by the
trailer and get anything and
yeah so did all sorts of things and you
can still have two people
yeah i reckon i've done yeah probably
like getting close to 100 now
little ones little ones and honestly i'm
probably getting worse as i go along
because we have a tattoo gun here oh boy
so if anything i noticed someone came in
from
if any of you are down by my toes
conveniently
if any of your graduates want a tattoo
to commemorate this lovely evening
you pierced your ear uh yeah not myself
um oh it'd be so funny please
bless you unless you're thinking it
might but i i i'm seeing you actually
are prepared oh yes you have this stuff
there yeah
no no she can touch you this isn't
actually my gun but i could i can
make do with it for sure are you
genuinely thinking about this
no no okay i didn't think you were
not all that's acting
ryan ryan didn't look so shocked because
you've already tattooed yourself haven't
you
yeah how did that go for you not great
what did you do uh it was uh
you know it was supposed to be a you
know like the clap
like a monster hand dropping a bloody
heart
but it it looks more like a like a
chicken
you know making love with a cactus or
something
i don't know what happened
friend had one at his house i liked a
doodle it's a bad combination
do you have a tattoo oh god i know
you're gonna ask oh no do you do you
yeah i do okay yeah where is it i went
to college in the 90s
look at me you just leave it there is it
a stamp
no god no thank god it a dolphin
no no no no is it uh no i don't know
what we're doing
the thing is the thing is there is
someone who works on our team
and uh they are a big margot
robbie fan and uh they
i would i say they're willing to do this
i mean they're very keen uh he's washed
his feet
talked them so would is it
i mean is it difficult to do this tomoji
thing no it'll be fine
yeah so adam your moment is here this is
happening okay
okay
so sit down beside uh while you're there
hey i
i i don't need to criticize my own
production team but you could have taken
your shoes and socks off first
it would have saved a little time you
knew this moment was coming i wanna do
some more real
okay okay here we go here we go you
don't have to do this if you don't want
it no honestly i kept saying that he
wants to do this he does
okay are you sure yeah okay
oh my god is this oh i know there's
something i have to say now this is
legally
uh don't try this at home
really don't i'll sit on this side of
you okay perfect okay here we go okay
okay in your own time that will it's not
that easy to do
no okay here we go i actually haven't
done one for a while
i'm sorry i'm probably more nervous than
you are to be honest sorry that's not
comforting i'm not gonna say that
that wasn't very professional i'm so
scared
i'm gonna say my hands are shaking but
you don't hear that
okay sorry
does it hurt it's a little little funny
yes
don't worry about your finest work
you do seem happy in your work i really
do
i'm not particularly good but i like
doing it
who's poker face adam very good
oh sorry is that alright
i can neaten it up like when we're off
backstage
[Music]